yassine est ce que je peux raconter
comment est venue cette date rigolade
qu'on veut faire ce soir
je viens sin vient souvent me voir et on
passe après 1h 1h30 dans la loge c'est
vrai et on parle tous les deux et il ya
sin me fait un petit peu le débrief de
l'émission j'ai dit frère mais tu m'as
tué jeudi mais vient de faire ici et j'y
viens de recevoir bientôt mal bien le
faire ici demain et voilà il est là
voilà comme ça
alors sachez que c'est une personne qui
n'est pas payé si une personne qui aime
la vie
j'aime les gens l'esma c'est comme ça
que je peux définir ça me touche que tu
10 ans l'enfant tout bonsoir à tout ça
me fait plaisir ça fait plaisir parce
que enfin je suis ici je me suis mangé
ça voilà j'essaie de mails faveur niveau
si vous insultez alors mon niveau et
hyper faible là j'ai dit aux producteurs
c'est quand même chaud si je reviens je
veux un truc plus quoi là je veux de
l'amour
après ma diva dans tpm pc une émission
populaire alors je me suis demandé c'est
quoi être populaire et voici ce qui est
populaire en france aujourd'hui
voilà il ya quelque chose l'homme donc
j'attends là c'est des bons moments
cette semaine et je vais encore me faire
clencher alors si vous m'insultez
belattar cerner les doter en parlant de
clash sert il cyril m'appelle il y a
deux jours vers 2h 28 du matin cyril
hamza frérot je suis à la boxe je me
prépare pour demain
qu'est ce qui se passe d'un combat me
dit non t'as pas vu quotidien jeune
cyril je regarde pas cotisent à ce que
je mange de la viande
je vois que patrick timsit alamo risques
connus avant instagram
c'est notre norman de l'époque il a dit
ça regardez et vu le nombre d'émissions
de télé à la con que j'ai fait j'ai même
le droit de la pénibilité au travail
sans l'émission de cyril hanouna recette
fait quatre très belles nuisances
sonores nuisances visuelles
ça te détruit deux neurones 7e réduite
en espérance de vie
c'est ce pauvre benjamin castaldi qui me
l'a dit sur son divan va j'aurai à la
démission calme-toi démocrate a les
épaules tu es là on en a vu d'autres tu
peux encaisser mais je vais montrer les
sms qu'aux voyageurs ce qui m'a choqué
c'est pas tant qu'ils attaquent cyril
ouais c'est qu'il s'en prenne à benjamin
castaldi
j'ai rencontré belgique jeudi mais
pourquoi tu fais là comme j'aime des
pubs à la con une des balles ce que ça
ça me permet de faire des choses de
qualité à côté quoi touche pas à mon
buzz mais c'est quoi cette merde ça me
permet de faire des pubs de qualité à
côté alors patrick moi je t'aime bien
s'attaquer à un homme déjà c'est pas
bien et s'attaque à son régime que vous
voyez tous les jours ils nous voient
nous chronique est en train de manger
des twitts des fondeurs guk ri devant
l'émoi l'huile à son petit port where we
mange comme ça des petites graines des
topinambours tu as perdu combien de
kilos benji à 10 ans mais un site ultime
ils ont aussi aussi une suite il dit
tout ça devant yann barthez alias bobo
premier empereur des stan smith et dieu
il est là et alors ils sont méchants
c'est le garde manger de la viande ça
arrange antilles pendant que baba
premier ses empereurs de la barca essaie
de réconcilier les français grâce à ces
débats bobo premier lui essaie juste de
réconcilier les maîtres du 3e
arrondissement avec les mêmes décisions
passées bonjour en quatre ans la faim
qu'il a rien fait à barcelone
d'ailleurs à peine à retrouver pépites à
regarder l'émission de lundi parce
qu'hier
voilà j'ai mis 24 armor m et surtout je
devais vraiment je me suis dit qu'est ce
que tu as fait un quand j'ai regardé
l'émission de lundi et je me suis dit
c'est du génie quand tu arrives à mettre
ensemble loana le coc vide
francis lalanne est un pédophile c'est
du joli mais le conducteur de l'émission
d'hier un camouflet alors tenez vous
bien glissé mesdames et messieurs on a
reçu le airbnb de luan
soit même plus les amis la famille on
reçoit le mec la loi un appartement il
s'appelle laurent segal awards
alors laurent merci déjà d'être là c'est
donc vendredi que laurent comment ça
s'est passé vous avez dit pourquoi vous
avez été dans l'appartement fait on vous
a dit qu'il y avait un problème qu'est
ce qui se passe vendredi soir 500 et il
a affecté pas parce que lohan a fait un
match nul 5 sans fil
ça sentait qu'ils sifflent et paie pour
l'assurance alors tu lui as demandé
après très sérieusement c'est l'abbé
d'assurance rien j'ai laissé mon
téléphone à ma part appelé aura aucun
dédommagement pour vous je pense là ce
avait peur il y aura un dédommagement
parce que des airbnb à un fonds
d'assurance dont il arrive je reviens à
la france à respirer ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que maintenant pour que loana
trouva airbnb ça va être chaud je pars
jamais dasani attention de loana je me
porte caution est un bon rétablissement
à loana on lui rappelle que un doliprane
ça suffit tu es belle revient parmi nous
autre sujet vous avez parlé ici de koh
lanta est exactement et vous suit la
journée avec le vrai obélix si on peut
plutôt que tuer des animaux dans
kolontar
à quand une association écolo qui va
dire il ya des palmiers qui ont été
maltraités
voilà si à pamiers qui témoigne cyril ne
faut pas le chauffer une va appeler pas
mis à dire très rotair pamiers est l'une
vient témoigner voilà les amis
la dernière fois qu'on a regardé koh
lanta c'est vrai qu'il ya des moments
durs il a eu avec la chef vous souvenez
la chef qui s'est marié houamed qui se
fait dorénavant appeler mohamed de koh
lanta c'est voilà c'est son nom de
famille il a voulu tuer une chèvre et
nous les arabes c'est vraiment un
rapport assez exclusif avec la viande et
les autres ont dit tu pas la chèvre elle
est enceinte et mohamed a répondu une
phrase d'arabes il a dit ça fera plus
soir là le front national contre 10%
merci moi m que je salue bisous à vous
me dire qu'il va pas bien en ce moment
ça après tablissements chers frères et
surtout il a dit il ya eu dans ce moment
au moment solennel c'est quand cyril a
demandé à ces crimes coeur cette
question c'est un truc de fou kéké
fleurs d'été moi je kiffe quand l'heure
d'été arrivent je vous dis je suis en
vacances d'ailleurs castaldi il est déjà
en mode vacances qu'il avait des
lunettes de soleil macro va poser cette
question qui kiffent l'heure d'été est
ce que la question qui fut l'heure d'été
sera au centre de la présidentielle
alors moi j'aime bien les votes mais les
chroniqueurs vous pouvez vous rebeller
la trousse de vote demain cirelli va
chauffer il va dire qui kiffent respirer
la suite on embrasse ambages du jour
regarder voilà voilà
le sziget les 21 autres marques un parc
à pour finir lundi tu as reçu encore une
fois eryl prayer away et moi c'est mon
chouchou regard des meilleures années
louana wihéries les pardons bien sûr
l'émotion est quelqu'un de respecté ici
quand il vient on sait qu'il va se
passer quelque chose
si on a une expression qui dit il y à
erie dans la demeure dans tous les sens
accru de lieu d'un lundi ils étaient
mignons nous a dit que lohan devait
vivre chez lui mais comme ça l alcôve
ida peut pas venir parce que la maire de
lille à la 92 ans ces voix là c'était
l'anniversaire de sa mère et lui acheter
un fraisier 12 euros au lieu de 14 x
important de savoir trop de détails eryl
comme l'om droite au but mais il nous a
quand même appris une nouvelle
incroyable en exclusivité pour tp raté à
ali j'ai retrouvé la trace du chien
aussi qu on avait perdu
je sais où est le chien donc demain je
vais essayer de récupérer le chien a pas
qui a dit l'histoire c'est pour le chien
le chat on m'a dit qu'ils étaient chez
eux
non le chien et au commissariat le
duriez au commissariat du 3e
arrondissement donc demain je vais faire
un saut qu'il contient voilà après avec
bienne be dolana le yach de l'aude
venus 30 millions d'amis des stars
déchues droite à l'émission de demain on
aura des nouvelles du poisson rouge de
francis lalanne s'est pas surtout
j'imagine les clubs du 3e arrondissement
dire michel je fais quoi du yach je le
mets en garde à vous parler pour finir
searidge et 39 ans ces jeunes par
rapport à certains chroniqueurs
c'est vrai je voulais dire bonsoir le
certains d'entre vous comme moi une
passion pour li na est ce qu'on va
devenir une séquence de bin alors niasse
et c'est quoi ces d'encyclopédie si on
gagne c'est archi de l'acier les
archives de la télé c'est par exemple et
ozzy tron qui finit à vous de marc
lambron dont il ya un café mais la
question que je me penche frère est ce
que dans trente ans lina rediffusera des
séquences de tpm p j'espère espère
[Musique]
à metz il dit arrêter sinon sinon sylvie
moreau non c'est toi qui m'aiment bien
de sortie allez vous asseoir
d'ailleurs ce que tu as osé dire hier
soir
[Musique]
voilà c'était un grand moment merci en
tout cas merci à la galerie à bientôt et
prenez soin de vous à bientôt
merci ma table dimanche au japon